okay um hello everyone my name is torbin
and uh I'm going to talk about a topic
today that features quite prominently in
in the book and um is actually quite old
but that I want to somewhat Revitalize
with this talk so let's get started as
you can see uh the topic is the Highland
Z Houser mechanism so what is that so
let's get started um in the setting of a
very classic matching market and that's
a market where you have an agents and
you have n indivisible Goods that you
want to distribute exactly to the agents
so you want to give exactly one good to
exactly one agent uh for example let's
say houses uh to these
guys and uh this Market that has
one-sided uh preferences
that are linear preferences given by
some numbers so these are cardinal
utilities every agent has a rational
number that signifies how much they like
a certain
good and uh this setting um has been
around for for many many years and
there's a very well celebrated paper by
Helen enaer from
1979 where they essentially give a very
nice mechanism um for this appliation
problem using what's called a a pseudo
market so the idea is essentially it has
four
steps uh step one is that it's always uh
difficult to deal with indivisible Goods
so there's a trick you can make the
goods divisible by turning each good
into one unit of probability shares that
you will later run a lottery over the
next step is that uh you turn the um you
turn the setting into a market and the
way you do that is you give every AG
agent one unit of a fake
currency and then now that you have this
so-call pseudo Market um this Market has
a an equilibrium uh
allocation so you can take this
equilibrium allocation from this market
and lastly uh you can use the pretty
wellknown brookoff annoyment theorem
which tells you that if you have an
allocation which in this case is a
fractional perfect matching between the
agents and the goods you can um run a
lottery based on these allocated
probability
shares okay so let me briefly give kind
of the formal setup of of this
mechanism basically as I mentioned there
are agents and goods and I will assume
that we have an equal number of agents
and goods and we want to assign exactly
to each other and importantly for this
talk I am specifically interested in
Cardinal utilities where the agents have
numerical preferences over the
goods and then highlight in cower
defined an equilibrium concept where
basically uh if you're given an
allocation over from Agents to from
Goods agents and prices which are non-
negative on the goods then these are
called an HC equilibrium if every agent
gets exactly one unit of these
probability shares meaning that the
total allocation is a fractional perfect
matching from Goods to
agents uh every agent spends at most
their budget their one unit of fake
currency and most importantly every
agent maximizes their utility under
these two constraints so they get a a
bundle of probability shares that
maximizes their Cardinal utilities under
the constraint that they get one unit of
good and they spend it most their budget
and sometimes there are multiple such
bundles in which case they get a
cheapest
bundle okay so why is this such a well
celebrated result uh the reason is that
these equilibria have many very nice
properties so one is that they are EnV
free or to be a little bit more exact X
anti eny free so um this Lottery no
agent would want to uh exchange their
own bundle of these shares with another
agents uh they are pero optimal meaning
that there's no way to improve uh one
agent without hurting another agent and
they also satisfy a weak notion of
strategy proofness that if the market is
in some sense large enough then agents
cannot um benefit by misreporting their
Cardinal
utilities okay and based on this you
might say that this particular setting
of of a matching Market is kind of a
solved problem um in particular highight
in zaro they actually showed that these
equilibria always
exists and moreover uh the only kind of
flaw of this is that okay it's not
perfectly strategy proof but actually
it's known that you cannot get EnV
freeness Pro optimality and strategy
provement at the same time so you might
consider this kind of a best possible
result and there's kind of this General
belief that once you've set up a pseudo
market now you have a very natural
mechanism you can give agent their fake
currency and then they can trade amongst
themselves and find this equilibrium
somehow and there's your mechanism but I
want to argue that uh in in this talk
that actually there is still a lot of
really interesting research in Cardinal
matching markets like this because uh
this problem is not quite solved and the
reason is that there are two major
deficiencies that uh this pricing based
approach has for matching markets the
first is already in the title of the
talk and I will get get into this in
more detail and that's the fact that
these equilibria are near impossible to
compute so both in theory and in
practice as we will
see and the second is that um when you
think about um this matching markets
that I just described with the HC
equilibrium it's a very restricted
setting it's linear utilities
one-sided um and you know if you compare
that to all the beautiful models we have
in general equilibrium Theory uh that
are pricing based there is a pretty big
pity of models for matching
markets okay so let's get started on the
intractability so in terms of computing
these
equilibria um there are essentially kind
of only three main results the first is
the original proof which uh shows that
the equilibrium exists and it uses
kakutani's fix Point theorem and it's
highly non-constructive and they say as
a remark that you know if you want to
compute the the allocation well you can
do like a grid search over the prices
which is extremely
inefficient then there is a an algorithm
that uses a technique called algebra
Excel decomposition and this algorithm
it's interesting maybe theoretically but
in practice even for say five agents and
five Goods you need somewhere like 10 to
the 80 steps if you run this algorithm
which is more than there are atoms in
universe and in terms of polinomial time
algorithms there is one algorithm but it
only works for B valued utilities where
every agent only has two types of
utilities a highly restrictive
setting so why has there been so little
progress uh on this computation so this
was a question that was asked recently
in in a paper by fani and Yan kakas and
they started giving some answers so the
the first thing is that um these
equilibria can be irrational so there is
an instance small instance like this
where there is a unique HD equilibrium
which is
irrational and from a complexity Theory
uh point of view they showed that uh
finding these HC equilibria is in a
complexity class called fixed p and
finding approximate equilibria is in a
complexity class called ppad now for
those of you that don't know what this
means so um basically these these
classes fix p and ppid you can think of
them as kind of analoges of the class NP
that you all know which is highly
believed to be intractable except that
in this setting we always know an
equilibrium exists so we are given the
assumption that one exists and we want
to find it both of these classes
represent problems of this type with one
major distinction being that we already
know HD equilibrial are irrational and
so they cannot actually be in this class
ppad which only allows rational
Solutions
but this kind of uh show so they show
that uh finding these equilibria is in
this class but perhaps the more exciting
problem is whether it is complete or
hard for these classes and one of these
um questions was resolved very recently
where um these uh long list of authors
here they they uh studied this problem
and they showed that finding an Epsilon
approximate HC equilibrium is in fact
ppad hard
uh for inverse polinomial
epsilons and kind of to bring this home
what does this mean so being ppad hard
means that it's kind of in the same
league as many other famous problems in
computational economics such as finding
like General Nash equilibria finding
Market equilibria in certain markets and
in fact it's even computational
equivalent to kakutani 6. theum and ra 6
the okay so that was a lot of bad news
but I think in in research bad news is
always good news because if something is
impossible then it opens a new direction
for interesting research and I think in
this case uh the path forward is that I
think we need to go back on Cardinal
matching markets and look at the
properties that we want to have so there
is kind of four properties that we want
from mechanisms in general um we want
things to be fair ideally NV free in the
setting we want efficiency ideally pero
optimality we want strategy proofness
ideally DS I and as a computer scientist
I want this I want polinomial time I
want a mechanism that you can actually
Implement and this raises so uh you know
as I said already by the way like just
these three together are are impossible
so you can kind of look at every single
combination of all these properties and
various results are known but what I
think is one of the most uh fundamental
problems is the question of just what
about just fairness and and uh and
efficiency so the HZ solution tells us
that there are uh Solutions which are
EnV free and perito optimal but we don't
know of any way to compute such
Solutions so there's a a major open
problem in Cardinal matching markets
which is to give a polinomial time
algorithm which finds perito optimal NB
free allocations in this very simple
linear one-sided matching Market setting
or indeed to show that this is hard um
both of these are are quite
interesting and in Wake of this major
open problem I want to pose the question
of what is actually the best possible
that we know right now so if you try to
fix um say pero optimality and
polinomial time what is the best
fairness guarantees that you can
actually
achieve and that brings me into my next
major topic which is an alternative uh
approach to Cardinal matching markets
which is called Nash
bargaining okay so Nash bargaining is a
very old idea and uh the idea of Nash
bargaining is that let's say you have
two agents who uh let's say own some
nice vacation homes so one agent has a
vacation home on the beach and the other
agent has a vacation home in the
mountains and they both like their
vacation homes but they don't want to
spend every single vacation there so
these two agents can meet and they can
say look you know I have this utility
right now you have that utility and
maybe we can bargain we can exchange
some time in our houses and improve our
situation together so uh formally
basically these two agents uh for every
possible way that they can kind of trade
their their time in their houses it
forms uh a set of uh possible
allocations and each of these
allocations has utilities for both
agents which forms this utility space
and there is some initial Point called
disagreement point which is where the
two agents started and Nash asked the
question of where will these two agents
end up with in some idealized bargaining
scenario um yeah so these are
disagreement
utilities and he um started wondering
about kind of what axioms we might make
for um this bargaining scenario and he
came up with four axioms the first two
are perito optimality and symmetry
symmetry meaning equal agents should be
treated equally in this bargaining
process and the last two I won't go into
too much detail in variance under apine
Transformations and Independence of
irrelevant Alternatives but the kind of
main thing I want to point out is that
under these axioms that Nash introduced
uh he showed that um assuming this space
of utilities is convex then there is
actually a unique Point called the Nash
bargaining Point somewhere uh above
these two disagreement lines which is
the ideal outcome of this bargaining
situation so the the theorem uh that he
showed is that if this set of utility
vectors is convex then there is a unique
Point s satisfying these four axioms and
this point is the maximizer of the
product of the utilities minus the
disagreement utilities this you might
also know as the Nash social
welfare now why is this uh interesting
to me as a computer scientist well the
reason is that this is inherently a
polinomial time thing because you're
maximizing a log concave objective over
a convex set meaning that if you take
the log of this you're maximizing a
convex function over over a convex set
and that's a convex program and there
are many uh practical and theoretical
results to solving convex
programs now Nash bargaining and these
kind of pricing based uh mechanisms
actually have uh a long history I don't
want to go into all the details but I do
want to point out two uh results the
first is the isenberg Gale program so
probably many of you know this that uh
if you have a linear Fisher Market which
is kind of the analog of this par that I
just described except there's no meshing
constraints so you can assign multiple
Goods to one person then uh it actually
turns out that Nash bargaining in this
setting is equivalent to linear fishal
market and they're both modeled by this
so-called Eisenberg Gale
program but as soon as you move into
other settings such as for example
linear aror de bro markets I turns out
that um Nash bargaining and pricing
mechanisms in general diverge they do do
not give the same results though Nash
bargaining uh often turns out to be uh a
rational convex program and have
rational
Solutions and in fact in some settings
there are very nice combinatorial and
strongly polinomial time algorithms
which is why I'm in particular
interested in applying these techniques
to matching markets where we have no
nice
algorithms okay so there's a a recent
work which studied Nash borging as a
tractable and real world alternative to
Highland Zer um this paper they give uh
various practical algorithms based on
comex programming techniques such as
Frank Wolf and cutting
planes and they show that you can easily
solve matching markets up to say 20,000
agents in an hour uh which again if you
compare that to the HZ solution where
even for n equals to five I will not be
able to guarantee you any solution ever
so um there's a rather big golf in terms
of what you can do
experimentally and also uh as I will
talk about a bit later there are many
other models of matching markets that
you can extend these techniques
to so the nice thing about U Nash
bargaining as I said already is that
it's a convex program but in particular
it's not just any convex program uh it
has a very particular form you're
maximizing the sum of the log utilities
over uh the space of feasible
allocations which in our case is
matchings and the matching polytope is
not just any polytope it has a lot of
nice
structure and using this structure uh we
showed that you can actually give some
very nice simple algorithms uh there's
in fact like a multiplicative weights
based procedure that you can use to
solve this problem and um there's also
uh conditional gradient type algorithm
which uses you know a matching solver as
a sub routine and uh using these
algorithms you can get much more
reasonable runtime balance compared to
you know exponential time you can do
things in like n log n over Epsilon
squar
um okay so now I want to kind come back
down to reality so what's the reason
that Nash bargaining is not the ultimate
solution well the reason is that a Nash
tting is neither Envy free nor strategy
proof so there are some very small
examples like this one uh and in fact
there there are even some examples that
use only zer1 utilities where Nash
bargaining does not give you an NV Free
Solution but I don't want to say that
Nash marging is not fair at all it does
have some fairness properties so one is
obviously one of the axim uh it's
symmetric it treats equal agents equally
which is kind of nice but very easy to
achieve but it also has two other
properties one is that it's
proportionally fair which means that if
you try to increase one agent's utility
by say a factor of two then you cannot
do that without harming the other agents
by a factor of one
half and also um Nash bargaining
satisfies a relaxed form of
proportionality or equal share fairness
meaning that every agent gets at least
half of what they would get if you just
assign the items totally at
random
okay now there is one uh last thing I
want to point out so Nash bargaining as
I said is very well understood from a
computational perspective but there is
one uh I think very interesting question
which is still open and that's the
question of Dynamics so Nash bargaining
in general um has certain there are
certain dynamics that converge to a Nash
bargaining solution where the two agents
bargain with each other but those
Dynamics turn out to be very uh natural
in this case of U matching markets so I
pose as an open question to find natural
decentralized Dynamics where the agents
interact in such a way that it converges
to this naturing
solution
okay now the last topic I want to talk a
little bit about is going beyond the
simple one-sided linear matching Market
setting so uh as I mentioned Highlander
cower is in some way is analogous to the
linear Fisher Market which is the most
Elementary model that we have in in
general equilibrium theory if you want
to go beyond this for example to things
like a linear Arrow de bro Market where
the agents already bring some endowment
of goods into the market and then trade
amongst each other or if you want to go
into markets that have nonlinear
utilities what can you
do the other um thing I want to point
out is uh there are
certain markets that are specific to
matching markets such as two-sided
markets like kidney exchange or
non-bipartite markets like roommates
markets where the same question can be
raised what can you do uh in terms of
extensions of Highland
CER okay so let's answer that question
for The Exchange
Market actually H and zakaa already
mentioned in their original paper that
while there is a very natural extension
of uh their equilibrium
to an endowment setting where agents are
trading equilibria in general fail to
exist and uh given this there there are
some ways around this so there is a a
model called Alpha slack equilibria
where you construct a hybrid model
between um a trading economy and uh an
HD model so basically you give everybody
just a tiny Epsilon of fake currency and
the rest happens through exchange and in
that setting equilibria do exist
and there is even a result where we show
that um there's a slightly relaxed
notion of this called Epsilon
approximate equilibrium where you can
give algorithms for B valued utilities
which is as I mentioned earlier also the
only case where we have algorithms for
HC okay and um there's one more uh
result I want to mention which is that
you might say okay but even for eror
equilibria do not always exist there are
certain conditions that you need uh for
example a well-known sufficiency
condition is that you have what's called
a strongly connected demand graph and
maybe under this condition you have an
ADHD equilibrium but in fact you know
that's not the case so there are many
examples where uh these adhc equilibria
do not exist even with 01 utilities and
further
restrictions but of course Nash
bargaining uh does still exist in fact
you know you have to probably look at
this twice to even see the difference
between this and the um the non-exchange
version the the difference is that we
include this disagreement
Point okay next I want to mention uh
two-sided
markets so for two- siding markets the
question was not actually raised in the
paper so the original HC paper as I
mentioned it already says well what
about extensions to endowments okay we
can't do it but they didn't actually
consider um these different markets that
are specific to to matchings Really of
two-sided uh markets where you have
agents on both sides or agents in a
non-bed setting and here I mean this
question is a little bit um General I
mean what exactly is a pricing based
mechanism however one thing I can tell
you is that in two-sided markets there
are in general no Envy free and Pito
Optimal Solutions so if you um have a
setting like this this is with symmetric
012 utilities so this Edge means that
both of these agents have utility two
for this pair these agents have utility
one for this pair and the rest is is the
edges which are not here represent
utility zero then in this setting there
is no fractional perfect matching uh
which is both EnV free and pero optimal
and the same goes if you go to
asymmetric uh 01 utilities so here this
means like this agent has utility one
for this agent but this uh agent has
utility zero for this
agent so uh same thing there there's no
NV free and PR to Optimal Solutions so
if you're looking for a pricing based
mechanism that has kind of the same
properties as HC where the prices are
independent of the agents and non-
negative and so on then they would imply
these properties so you cannot
find okay let me talk briefly about NV
free and PR to Optimal allocations in
general so these examples that I just
showed you you might notice that
actually a little bit hard to verify
that they are examples because uh there
are of course infinitely many
allocations which uh could be and free
optimal but as a kind of General meta
result you might say for any matching
market like this with linear
utilities you can see that um there is a
kind of a trick which is that the every
free Solutions in general form a polytop
so this is for example in the case of a
one-sided Market where you have agents
and goods then uh the set of all EnV
free Solutions is given by the matching
constraints and additional constraints
that say that uh no agent envs and other
agents and what this means is that if
you look at the the space of all uh
utilities that can be achieved by
allocations the um the set of enf free
um utilities is a polytope inside of the
space and uh a solution is EnV free and
PR optimal if it lies on this Frontier
and it's also uh on the boundary of this
nvre polytope and then probably already
from this picture uh you can see that
using some standard polyhedral Theory
you can show that uh EnV free uh there's
always an EnV so if there is an EnV free
prodct optimal solution
then there's always and ref free per
Optimal Solutions which are vertices of
this polytop and that means that you can
find these
Solutions um in practice typically in
the following way which is that you can
just uh find some random vertices of
this polytope for example by optimizing
in certain directions so you might
optimize an Direction use an LP solver
to find a Vertex check if it's per
optimal which is another linear
program and you can repeat this until
you might find if if you're lucky an NB
fre prod to Optimal solution as I said
for um the one-sided linear Market such
Solutions always exist because of HC in
other markets uh they often do not
exist and that's basically you know how
I I constructed these
examples okay couple more minutes so let
me um mention some more positive results
also so in the case of these two-sided
matching markets again not a big
surprise is that Nash bargaining extends
easily uh in fact here the only
difference is that you sum over agents
on both sides um the algorithms to
solving this program efficiently are
affected a little bit so it's not quite
as easy as it seems but it's still
possible to solve this very efficiently
both in practice and in theory even if
you add some some endowments as
well and in the case of uh 01 utility
you actually get a little bit more so
notice that when I introduced the
counter examples I showed you an example
for symmetric 012 utilities and
asymmetric 01 utilities and there's a
reason for these two examples it's
because if you actually go to symmetric
01 utilities somewhat surprisingly there
are actually um these pseudo Market
equilibria equilibria where the agents
have equal fake
income um this is an old result by Bona
and Mulin but uh technically they they
don't show that it's polinomial time but
you know if you're familiar with this uh
01 HZ algorithm by vazirani and
yanakakis then it's fairly easy to show
that you can also do this in polinomial
time and in fact these equilibria also
exist uh in the case of non-bipartite
graphs so even if you remove the bipar
tiess condition the 01 case goes all the
way to the end you can do it in
polinomial time on General graphs and as
soon as you add three utilities or
asymmetry it all breaks
down and yeah n bargaining same story in
a non-bipartite graph uh as as I'm sure
many of you know the meching polytope
gets a little bit complicated you have
exponentially many constraints but there
are various techniques to get around
this
too okay and last thing is I want to
just very briefly touch on nonlinear
utilities so nonlinear utilities are uh
a bit interesting in this case of of
matching markets so if you start from
the original setting that Highland and Z
cower studied where you have indivisible
goods and you essentially do this trick
of creating probability shares you very
naturally end up with linear utilities
because the agents care about the
expected utility that they get from the
lottery however uh there are settings
like this um say house sharing problem
that I told you about earlier in Nash
bargaining where there are the agents
have preferences are not quite linear
for example I might want a certain mix
of the beach and the uh Mountain Home
more than just you know having the beach
home or the mountain home because I like
variety so that's a case of a nonlinear
utility and um it turns out that under
certain conditions on on the linear uh
or on these utility functions equilibria
do exist though of course this is highly
nract so it uses very similar techniques
um with kakutani fix Point theorem we
have no idea how to compute this
equilibria and also it doesn't quite
cover all uh utilities that you're
interested
in whereas with with Nash bargaining
again you can do pretty much anything so
you can uh compute even just
nonseparable P linear uh utilities such
as Leon utilities you can compute up to
thousands of Agents quite easily
and uh we actually showed that for
separable p linear functions uh the
utility functions concave of course
separate separable pewi linear concave
utility functions you can um find
Solutions and polinomial time as well
and lastly I have one more open question
which is that I now introduce to you all
these various models that you cannot
solve with HZ where we either know
pretty well that you cannot solve them
or we just know that uh they're very
likely to be computationally intractable
and so I want to kind of uh Revitalize
this this research and Cardinal matching
markets and ask the question of what are
the trade-offs that we can achieve in
terms of efficiency and fairness for
example for two-sided meing markets um
or for nonlinear utilities Etc uh and of
course what of what of that is
achievable in polinomial time so I I
leave you with that question and I hope
you're all now more interested in
Cardinal matching markets than you were
before and uh yeah that's
[Applause]
it thank you to I guess we have time for
questions
so before I just want to make a comment
about
lunch s said for lunch um if you want
you can go next door to the business
school that's the closest distance there
but if you walk south some bankrupt
there are s restaurants if you're very
hungry there's a very good Chinese
restaurant with you know enormous Sur
otherwise if you continue walking down
to sandwich places
so yeah so one of the important things
about zacker was that after they
allocated probabilities there
exist right so because you can typically
use the the same technique so the way
that they implemented it yes so you can
use that even for non-bipartite
um markets and that is polinomial time
so there is a polinomial Time way to do
this
implementation um there's also a lots of
interesting questions about uh the
actual integral allocations that come
out of this uh like whether the integral
allocations have some fairness
properties as well a lot of interesting
research there but yeah I that
yeah so it's yeah so the Highland is a
cower achieves those properties but it's
difficult to compute so we know that
it's hard to compute the equilibrium not
equilibrium just two properties yes so
just finding those two is is hard yeah
well we don't know if it's hard that's
another we can just write out no so it's
because the Pito optimality is
not because the
isod is important that in
that take objective say maximum Ware
going to achieve so you can optimize
over let's say the NV fre and and pick a
direction and go as far as but that
gives you a a solution which is optimal
among like PR optimal among the en free
Solutions but there are en free Sol like
I
like there are many examples where you
you pick a direction and it gives you an
EnV free solution that is optimal among
all EnV free Solutions but if you there
are solutions which are uh not envy free
but which are better for
everyone so that's yeah yeah so that's
kind of the hard part is that it's easy
to find Solutions which are optimal
among aeree just by Maxim like running
linear programming but finding Solutions
which are uh burito optimal overall and
and free those that's
hard yeah so one problem with Nash
bargaining is that it's not mon
to yeah it's so Nash bargaining has has
multiple multiple issues so it's uh very
yeah there's also in terms of another
thing I didn't really talk about too
much is in terms of the
um in terms of
strategy proofness like you have a lot
of benefits in misrepresenting your
disagreement points um yeah so there are
definitely various various issues that's
why I think but this is as far as I know
the best we know in terms of fairness
properties for matching markets which
leaves like a pretty big gap that I'm
very interested
in okay I think
um we're well on time so and I guess I'm
ending the session and uh yeah feel free
to go to lunch and when when is it when
we restart 13 1:30 okay
[Applause]